imagine a world in which everyone paid
their fair share of taxes to have those
revenues keep our schools our hospitals
and our public transport running like
clockwork but it's not a perfect world
some multinational companies operating
in Europe don't pay their fair share of
tax and that means billions in lost tax
revenues so that's money that's not
going towards our schools tax money
that's not going towards our other
public services like buses and trains
this tax avoidance by large
multinationals can also result in a
higher tax bill for everyone else tax
avoidance is made possible by all the
loopholes complexities and
inconsistencies in the tax laws of
different EU countries if one country's
tax laws are not in tune with the others
multinational companies can take
advantage and they do because every year
about 1 in 5 euros of corporate tax is
lost to tax avoidance that's why the
European Commission is pushing back it's
time to stop imagining a simpler system
and start building it it's time for fair
and effective taxation for all Europeans